hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be continuing our coverage of the 2019 a
US Chess Championship today we're gonna
be looking at the two youngest
competitors they face off Sam Savion
playing the white pieces he's 18 years
old he's the youngest American ever to
become an expert as well as a
grandmaster at the age of 13 his
opponent playing the black pieces the
youngest competitor in the field that's
a wonder Liang he's 15 years old he's an
extremely strong Grandmaster he is the
current reigning US junior champion that
hell is how he was invited to this field
so we'll go ahead and get into it with
Sam starting out pawn to e4 and then we
had the caro-kann with pawn to c6 very
strong defense pawn to d4 we get into
the classical variation after pawn to d5
Knight to d2 we do see the exchange and
then Bishop down here to f5 Knight to g3
Bishop back to g6 pawn age 4 just the
mainline Ponce 8 chicks they finally
break the main line after Knight to f3
the most common move from here is going
to be Knight to d7 if they continue down
this line usually C pawn to h5 forcing
the bishop to come back here Bishop h7
Bishop to a d3 attacking the bishop
after the bishop comes off the board the
Queen comes up here this is the main
line they change things up slightly it
doesn't get too crazy from here instead
of the Knights coming to d7 instead pawn
to e6 but after this Knight comes to e5
attacking the bishop yes the knight
would have come here to d7 stopping that
but usually the bishops still gonna be
forced back after the pawn comes to h5
here Bishop back to h7 and then Bishop
to d3 they still have the exchange on
the board something I think would have
been interesting instead of Bishop to d3
because I do feel like the pawn to e6 is
a nice novelty here but Queen to h5
seems pretty interesting put a lot of
pressure on in the Kings side of the
board
you know you're not gonna see something
like pawn to g6 forces the the queen to
move but Queen back here to f3 now
putting a lot of pressure on the square
f7 if you were to continue for black
pawn to f6 the knight comes back c4
White has a very solid structure
you know what the pawn here on h4 why
it's usually gonna be looking to castle
on the Queen side you can see all the
air in front of the King on the Kings
side of the board for black all these
pawns here there's a lot of weakness
that y can start to chip away at so I
think that would have been an
interesting variation for white to try
out but instead he decided to go with a
common theme with Bishop to d3 and just
exchange those bishops off the board and
at this time we do see the Knight to d7
it's not getting to outside the line of
what we're used to seeing in the
mainline Bishop to f4 just developing
that Bishop also opening up the door if
white wants to castle on the Queen side
Knight to f6 and then exactly that
castle on the Queen side followed by
Bishop to e7 black could if you wanted
to decide to castle on the Queen side at
some point but this Bishop here on f4
does make it less likely just because
there would be a discovered attack at
some point with the nights here on e5
moving depending on where the King ends
up much safer to just castle on at the
King side of the board now Queen to f3
over here
starting to attack on the King side
knowing now where exactly black will
probably end up castling want to start
to attack as much as they can on the
King side of the board so once I attacks
on the King side Mike's gonna go ahead
and send his forces over to the Queen
side the board so Queen to a5 maybe we
met with King to be one protecting this
pawn here on a to one of their moves has
Queen it to d5 just centralizing that
and then Queen back here to e to why
it's not ready to give up his Queen is
playing the white pieces does feel like
he does have a slight advantage right
now so it does not want to exchange at
this current moment and then we see pawn
to b5 now this is a small little trap
there's a few nuances every
in a chess game where you have to look
and see okay doesn't want to exchange
but did he just really give up this pawn
here on g2 he did not that would be a
mistake if the Queen came and took here
on g2 because there's not a lot of
squares for this Queen to retreat back
to we can clearly see you can't come to
f3 or e4 so it really comes down to can
they ever get back to d5 white and this
situation we'll be able to let's say
first take here on d7 if there's an
exchange here maybe pawn up here to d5
the queen can't capture because the pawn
would just recapture definitely matter
where black goes here eventually pun up
here to c4 this is stopping all the
places that the black queen can retreat
to so in this case maybe rook over here
to d8 and then rook to g1 forcing the
Queen to move here it is going to fall
no matter where it goes so definitely
not gonna be a good place for black to
go to does not want to capture that pawn
instead decides to go and play pawn to
b5 first first attacking on the Queen
side of the board and then giving him
some control of this c4 square so the
pawn can't come up to c4 here and trap
in the Queen so after that we do see
pawn to f3 says okay you've protected
over here now I need to protect my pawn
on g2 not only protecting it with the
ponty on f3
but now opening up for the Queen to also
protect it as well black continues to
push on the Queen side of the board with
pawn to b4 rook to e1 just centralizing
the rook castle on the Kings side so now
it's time to go and get this rook swing
over to the Queen's had really started
tacking on the Queen side of the board
Knight to e4 just centralizing that
Knights rook over here to see eight and
then pawn to g4 so you can start to see
the push happening here on the Queen
side Queen over here to b5 I think in
this situation I wonders looking at and
says okay you have a stronger attack
than I do you're controlling the center
of the board you have a lot of pawns
starting to push forward you can easily
bring your rooks over here I would like
to exchange some material with you can
you go ahead and change your Queens off
the board here Sam
not having any of it he decides to bring
his night up here take on d7 here taking
that night does not want to exchange and
black can't just come down and take you
know whites already taken an eye right
here if you see the Queen come down and
take on e2 then then I can come to f6
check now White's taking two minor
pieces pretty much something has to give
here doesn't matter what take so let's
say the pawn takes on f6 has to come out
of check here now white can take this
Queen and white is up a minor piece so
that's not going to be good instead
after the Knight takes here on d7
tonight it's going to recapture and then
Queen over here to g2 avoiding the Queen
exchange here on e two were up here on
b5 all right so once the Queen comes
over here to g2 you can really start to
feel that Sam has a strong attack going
on the King side of the board everything
is gearing up for the pawn to push here
to g5 has his bishop his knights his
Queen right here
has another pawn here on h4 start to
blow this up
get your rooks over here should be a
very strong attack that Sam has here we
see black continued
I wonder plays at King to h8 and then
the moment of truth here all the the
computer engines were ready all the
commentators were saying okay g5 is the
move and then we see Sam play Queen to
d2 but a little interesting definitely
expected the pawn to g5 seemed to have
other plans here and almost caught a
wonder off guard because I feel like he
made an inaccurate move here he played
rook to d8 it was almost like if you
didn't play g5 you must have found
something better than that that I don't
think anyone else saw and so trying to
compensate and figure out how do I now
defend this new attack that I was not
expecting and so from here we see the
bishop come to d6 Bishop comes back to
f8 and then Queen up here to f4 so you
can you can see that blacks in full
defense mode
usually we don't want to have your
bishops back here on the eighth rank
here but that's
exactly what we see black doing King to
g8 does want to protect this pawn here
on f7 being attacked by the Queen right
here
now we see pawn to g5 starting to blow
up the the Kings side the board a little
bit pawn to h5 so alone right there
Bishop to c7 attacking the rook I think
it would also be a really good move just
to go ahead and take this Bishop yes
it's a it's a piece that's not doing a
lot but if you take this Bishop right
here maybe after the rook takes now the
Queen can come up here attacking this
knight how does black really continue
here if he brings his queen over here to
d5 then Y can just take material here on
b4 has a good solid foundation instead
let's say the Knights gonna come to b6
you know we can clearly see it's not
gonna come to f6 it's gonna fall to the
pawn but maybe Knight to b6 from here
pawn to g6 just pushing more on the the
King side of the board here in this case
maybe the King comes here we do see an
exchange on the board after the pawn
takes though how does black continue if
it takes with his rook or the King
doesn't really matter now the knight can
come up here to d6 and fork both of
these rooks now so not the easiest fine
to move much easier as you're analyzing
these games after the fact but just
showing you some some options he had in
the game instead of playing at the
bishop here to c7 with the rook under
attack black brings his rook over here
to e8 Bishop centralizes with E 5 rook
comes back they do have a two-fold
repetition eventually after rook to e8
we see the Knights come back to g3 why
does get a sense that he has the upper
hand so Sam's not looking to draw in
this position instead brings the knight
back here to g3 Knight over here to b6
after the bishop takes the pawn is going
to recapture so it does give up the only
bishop he has left but does leave a
wonder with the the double pawns here on
the B file Knight takes on h5 rook over
here to d8 rook to e5 attacking the
Queen and then rook down here to d5 now
far as how white wants to continue in
this spot has a few options here but
decides to go and bring his rook over
here to g1 I think another option
instead of this is is absolutely just to
play Knight to f6 because how does black
really continue here if he takes with
this pawn right here then just the pawns
going to recapture if the rook takes hey
that's fine the pawns gonna take here
but then you're gonna start to swing his
rook over here there's no way to really
stop this maybe King to h7 Queen up here
g5 you can start to see here that things
are going extremely bad for black you
can always bring your rook here to g7 it
is you know this bishop can't take it
because it's being pinned down by the
Queen this is also threatening Queen to
f7 so things are extremely bad
so Knight to f6 I think is a stronger
move but decides to go and play rook
here to g1 then the rook takes we do see
an exchange on the board pawn takes on
e5 not willing to give up the Queen just
yet Queen on here - E - Queen over here
- a g4 ponit g6
forcing the the rook or the excuse me
the knight to move and you don't in this
position even though it looks like this
pawn is open it's not if the Queen takes
here on e5 it's just absolutely deadly
after the move Knight to f6 this is
check but then how does black continue
here if he takes it okay well that's
gonna be bad because the pawn takes this
is check there's no way to really stop
it Queen to g4 you can see because the
Queen and the rook behind it protecting
it it doesn't really matter where black
goes it is going to be a checkmate if we
come back and say you know why would the
the pawn take here okay well the Queen
doesn't want to take is then the Queen's
just going to fall here the only other
option though is for the King to come to
h8 but then it's just checkmate
automatically so not a lot of good moves
that black has here so does not want to
be taking with his Queen here on e5 so
as we continue after Queen to g4 pawn g6
forcing the knight to move
this is check King moves out of the way
Queen to e4 and then we see the exchange
and this this lets me know that same
just couldn't find the attack he's been
looking for for so long he decided to go
ahead and give up his strongest piece
still has a very good position this is
more of a closed structure where it
where pawns are really locked up and so
Knights are gonna fare extremely well in
this but definitely know that what would
have liked to hold on to his queen as
much as possible the black queen was not
really coordinated with his other pieces
it was just kind of behind enemy lines
trying to be a nuisance but really white
had more of a coordinated attack going
on rook to d8 you can clearly see want
to get the rooks to the open file start
to attack King to c1 here defending both
the D 2 square and at the d1 square here
rook to a8 we do see a two-fold
repetition here as they just exchange
moves here and then rook to e1 King down
here g7 you can start to get your King
ball into the game once the Queen's are
off the board for sure Bishop to e7 King
a c1 look to h4 attacking the pawn right
here so some defense going on with rook
to h1 pawn to b5 yes pushing on the
Queen side but there's just no strong
attack that a wonder has here rook to
the 8th just coming back King to see one
now centralizing the rook good thought
there's no way to really attack anything
the bishop can't do too much because all
these ponds are really just defending
each other can't get behind enemy lines
because there's so many pawns here the
Knights definitely the better minor
piece in the endgame rook to d4 recover
here to e1 defending his nights here
pawn to c5 so it's a nice little outpost
for the rook right here pretty easy to
kick this off if white wanted to at some
point King 2b to pawn to c4 trying to
blow up the Queen side the board that's
really the only thing that black has
potentially going for him
pawn takes here on c4 rook here to e3
Bishop comes back f8 you can see this
bishop it's clearly not doing anything
it's not even maneuvering to go
somewhere else there's just no good
squares for it to go to pawn to c3 rook
down here to d1 Knight to d6 great
little outpost move says hey if you want
to exchange material that's fine I will
gladly have my past politics square rook
to d2 King down here to b1 we do see an
exchange right there and then after rook
to e4 rook to c2 and this is where are
things I think things continue to go
downhill for for black here because yes
he could potentially try to take this
palm but it's so easy to protect this
with rook to c4 and now he can start to
attack with his rook as well just eyeing
on this C file here get behind enemy
lines really started to attack with his
knight as well you know rook to c7 and
both his knights and his rook or
attacking the f7 square the bishop
cannot defend the light square so all in
all yes this is attacking but there's
just no good moves for black in my
opinion rook to d2 recognizing that's
not going to do too much attacking the
knight here so the knight comes up to e8
King to g8 and then the rook comes and
gets involved into the game with rook to
c8 pawn down here to f5 the knight comes
back to the outpost here on d6 King g7
now check King comes back here to g8
rook to d7 so just doubling up here on
the D file rook to f2 attacking the
backward pawn here on f4 but white says
yeah I don't I don't even care that's
not what the game is about if you want
to attack that that's fine but that's
not gonna win you the game
miscalculation I think from a wonder
standpoint he decided to go ahead and
take this but this is a losing battle
just from a sheer calculation standpoint
because pawn to c5 here rook down to f1
yes there is going to be the ability to
bring this own pond down here on the F
file but the pawn can push here on c6 no
way to stop this pawn to f3 pawn c7 and
then after the Queen on CA
we do see the rook over here b1 king
takes yes black has his own queen but
now it just comes down to can white
survive and it's a game of putting your
opponent in check and not sure if we
want to just thought that he could have
a perpetual check continue to do this
for his opponent but this knight on d6
doing so much work blocking this bishop
from getting involved into the game can
easily just get his King behind over
here all this defenses just no way to
continue to check his opponent black
does a good job of trying oh you see it
marching up the board right here
eventually though Knights to e4 is the
last move where black resigns and
probably even a better move here and
instead of the knight coming down here
Queen takes on g6 okay now the bishop
can't move at all also threatening at
some point Queen to g7 checkmate so if
the Kings gonna get chased around by the
Queen here but pretty easy I think for
the the King to get behind here maybe
end up eventually on something like e 7
but after the the move Knight to e4
I wanted to decided that the same has
the victory no way to win this one so
the eighteen-year-old does defeat the
fifteen-year-old
in round 2 so congratulations to him
hopefully you enjoyed this round you
know it wasn't perfect chess but always
good to see innovative openings that we
don't see too often and see some of the
top young players in the world how they
approach the game very different than
the same openings in the same theory
that we see all the time so it's
refreshing to me to analyze these games
but I do hope that you are enjoying it
let me know what you think thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in round
number 3